hey this is presh talwalker there are
168 prime numbers less than one thousand
what is the sum of all prime numbers
less than one thousand there are four
answer choices a 11
569 b
76127 c 57
298 D eighty one thousand seven hundred
and forty four
I saw this problem on math stack
Exchange
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
contains the given information that
there are 168 prime numbers less than
one thousand
a prime number is a number greater than
one that only has itself and one as a
factor
the first few prime numbers are 2 3 5 7
and 11. now unless you have a special
talent you probably haven't memorized
all 168 prime numbers less than one
thousand and even if you did know all of
these prime numbers it would take a long
time to add them up so we're going to
solve this problem by using logic we
just need to eliminate the answer
choices that don't make sense and what
remains must be the answer so let's work
it out we know that we want to sum
168 prime numbers
every prime number greater than 2 must
be an odd number because otherwise an
even number greater than 2 would be
divisible by two making it not Prime
so we know that of the 168 prime numbers
167 of them are odd numbers
now we are adding an odd number of odd
numbers so their sum will be an odd
number
2 is an even number and we're going to
add an odd sum to that meaning the
result will be an odd number
so we know that the sum of these 168
prime numbers will be an odd number
so let's look at our answer choices
we can eliminate C and D because those
are even numbers
so All That Remains is to distinguish
between A and B so how can we do that we
need some way to estimate the sum of
these prime numbers well we can't do
that directly but what we can think
about is the sum from 1 to 168.
so we could use the formula n multiplied
by n plus 1 over 2 where n is equal to
168. we substitute in and then do some
arithmetic to get the result of
14196. now the first few prime numbers
are 2 3 5 7 and so on and we can see the
first prime number is greater than one
the second prime number is greater than
two and so on so the sum of the first
168 primes must be larger than the sum
of the numbers from 1 to 168 so we know
the answer can't be a because 11 569 is
less than fourteen thousand one hundred
and Ninety Six that means the correct
choice is B seventy six thousand one
hundred and twenty seven
and that's the answer
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a time
foreign
[Music]